Hãy hào dưới phút người mẹ ở lặng sương tìm thế con trái mất tích sau ba miếm ôn năm.
Năm 2028, sau ba miếm ôn năm 1 mọi tìm con, ba ôn tìm mình ở lặng sương đàn đến đầu thương sản vui có thứ,
tết này, lập bản thử trói.
Thế nhưng, chỉ một tình sau lời giản ấy, một cuộc gọi video suyên bên dưới đã xuất hiện,
nối lại sự dây tình thăm tử trường đã đích gái từ 1 năm, một nghiên triển trăm chính vý tư.
Kếm đưa bà trở lại ngày cuốc hành bà miếm ôn năm trước, khi bản rất theo con trái đầu lòng tiên khoảng đi bán trẻ giảo kệ sinh tận động đúc kinh.
Chỉ một lúc đứng đợi mẹ trong bóng sâm, cầu bếm mấy tùy đã bị hai kẻ số lửa gà,
giấn đi bịch tích qua những cạnh dửa biên giới, kể từ ngày ảy, không bêm nào mấy mẹ thuối phúc thường con.
Có lúc quận chi, bà định giả làm người điên để dễ dạng vượt biên xăng Trung Quốc tình con,
bởi lòng lúc nào cũng như có tạm đã đẹn hạc.
Ở nơi xử hội, anh hoàn được gia đình mới nhận đôi và yêu thương,
nhưng trong thân tâm anh chưa bao giờ quyết mình là người Việt Nam.
Suốt 25 tự khi chưởng thành, anh mệt mại tình đường về với phòng tay gia đình dù mạnh mỗi chỉ là cái tên của chăm mẹ.
Bước ngoạt đến vào tháng 18 năm, môi cuộc gọi từ 12, nói có người bên Trung Quốc đang tình gia đình,
mọi thông tin đều chung khó khối an trải.
khi cuộc gọi video bở ra, mà mình không kiên được nước mắt khi nhìn thấy khun mặt người danh ông xa lãnh như lại quá đối thương quành.
Chỉ cần y hương mặt, tôi biết đó là giọt mẫu của mình,
mọi người tàn biến khi chẳng trái dương ngon tay măng với xa giá trước mạnh hình.
Tiến hợi chà xeo lên trong nước mắt, đúng là con rồi,
hết lại hàng trình và mi mốt năm đặng đựa chương.
Ngày trường về, hoàn xa vào lòng mẹ như đối chẻ lấy bệnh năm nào.
Anh nhận hào bằng phụn tính Việt bập bệ, mẹ ơi, nhà của con là ở trong bụng mẹ.
Bà mi mốt năm lưu là, tặng đá trong lòng với mẹ của cuộc đá được nhất bỏ.
Từ nay, tất của gia đình bà mình đã thực sự trọn vệ,
khi giọt mẫu thích lạc đã tìm thấy đường về với phòng tay mẹ.